das heisst yves wäre mit seinem sprung
hier olympia verdächtig münchen freuen
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge minecraft heute am 26
ich habe heute die erste folge am start
wo ich mal einfach dieses neue system
ausprobiert habt ihr wisst natürlich ist
läuft schon eigentlich seit zwei wochen
habe ich mit einem vorproduzieren blabla
das neue system mit den formularen und
ich muss sagen es war echt eine richtig
gute idee dass mir das vorgeschlagen
wurde und das jetzt so gemacht habe weil
ich habe alles richtig sortiert ich habe
für diese folge einfach so viele fächer
schalte ich ab spieler für die nächsten
zehn millionen also sind echt cool
effects am start und ich glaube ich
mache heute sogar 66 einmal war ich cool
drauf wenn ich wirklich will drauf bin
ich auf jeden fall freuen wenn du bis
zum ende dran bleiben würde und wir
fangen an mit fekter numero uno
dieser effekt wurde mir zugesendet von
robert hexe und meinen bruder nämlich
einen dorfbewohner und zwar der
dorfbewohner hat natürlich eine ganz
normale nase das sieht man auch bei mir
als kind der dorfbewohner hat eine nase
ich bin übrigens immer in den sechs
folgen mittlerweile mit einer diamant
rüstung am start einfach weil ich mir
denke irgendwie passiert immer irgendwas
und ich bin immer irgendwie was fliegt
in die luft und ich bin meinen gedroht
deswegen sicherheit geht vor und ich hab
hier waren rüstet der paranoide naja
jedenfalls sehe schon die nase von dem
alter kann zwar auffällig anzugucken wir
jetzt einfach in mich verliebt ich
glaubte sich mit mir planen höher auf
guck mir nicht an
ihr seht schon die nase von dem bewegt
sich nicht die bewegt sich nämlich von
einem manager nur wenn er einen trank
getrunken hat allerdings eine hexe
tv-kult g1 so bei der hex ist es
allerdings so ihr seht schon die hacker
2 am start
die hexe da bewegt sich die nase
dauerhaft seht ihr die bewegst zuletzt
ein bisschen die ich einfach dauerhaft
irgendwie aufbau seines kacken effekte
blatt
da ist jetzt gut dass sich die nasen
bisher
das ist übrigens auch der grund warum
ich jetzt gerade kein tech spektrum ab
weil in dem sex weihnachtsspeck haben
die hexen keine nase sondern nur so
komische glatte haut und hier seht ihr
schon wieder bei dem bewegt sich das nur
wenn er etwas trinken bei der hexe die
ich andauernd irgendwie auch irgendwas
drauf da bewegt sich die ganze zeit und
da würde ich sagen weil das eigentlich
effekte mariens dann kann ich mir nun
zum zweiten effekt der schon damit zu
tun hat dass ich mir hier beispielsweise
einfach mal so ganz viele verschiedene
sachen raus nehmen die einfach ganz
willkürlich jetzt irgendwie umher
gegriffen sind dann immer noch so ganz
classic in diesem blog und zwar kennt
jetzt ja wenn ich hier so bin im
creative natürlich und ich klicke auf
dem blog darauf beispielsweise auf
dieses geschenk oder so und denke mir
sowas hätte ich eigentlich ein anderer
blog aber zum beispiel mit putenfleisch
mit der mittleren maustaste kenntnis
aller ich glaub ich hab sogar schon mal
gesagt dadurch bekommt man an diesem
blog auf dem angriff drauf guckt das
kann ich beispielsweise auch mit der
ketten hose ok mit der ketten hose war
bloß beispiel gerade aber ich nehme die
verzauberte buch keine draufklicken dann
ist es auch so kann diese diesen orangen
farbstoff nehmen da drauf klicken und
kann theoretisch auch im ballwerfen
schrank nehmen okay da jetzt drauf
gekriegt weil sich schon hatte klicke
ich mal hier auf das eis drauf habe ich
eins nämlich lapislazuli erz klickt dann
mal darauf habe ich dies ich kann das
gebratene kaninchen nehmen darauf
klicken allerdings ok spinnen auge
natürlich kann ich es fängt immer an zu
regnen in den folgen
ich bin so gelte jedenfalls habt ihr rad
schon sehen bei der ketten rose wenn ich
hier auf den schnee mal drauf klicken
da passiert gar nichts wenn ich auf das
wurde geschenk clique natürlich ich habe
schon ein rotes geschenk im inventar
allerdings bei der kette passiert dann
nicht weil das liegt nämlich an diesen
items die ihr hier findet wenn ich
beispielsweise mal hier sonst wärt nehme
oder hier sonne diamond oder hier mal
die holzhacker oder hier eine spitzhacke
oder mal eine andere oder so
beispielsweise ich mach mal eben die
anderen slots noch voll mit dem roten
geschenkt und mit etwas dahinter
jetzt ist ja alles voll und jetzt
eigentlich wenn man alles verliert und
man klickt auf dem blog drauf
beispielsweise mit der mittleren
maustaste bekommt man diesen schnee blog
anstelle des diamant schwerer als sonst
irgendwo hin katapultiert werden kann
ihr seht schon dass es auch im inventar
liegen sodass das blöde spinnen auge das
geht auch nicht mit dem holzschwert
diamant holzwerkstätten hose diana
spitzhacke blabla bleibt die ganze zeit
drauf genug funktioniert nicht hier mit
funktioniert dann wieder mit den ganz
normalen blöcken aber mit solchen sachen
wie kampf oder werkzeugen um mit man
halt noch anfang an mit dem kompass ist
wiederum nicht so obwohl er ihm auch den
weg weist
wenn ich jetzt mit dem kompass hier
draufklicken seht ihr schon da bekomme
ich das geschenk aber beispielsweise
wenn ich eine angenehme und hier
draufdrücken bekomme ich auch nicht auf
jeden fall eine ganz interessante sache
vielleicht wisst ihr warum das mit den
sachen ich gehe jetzt kommen sie danach
das liegt am entity und blauem blut
jedenfalls meint diese personen die mir
das zu gesendet hat sie möchte anonym
bleiben oder ich soll den youtube namen
angeben und auf youtube heißt er mein
date also mein date ohr und er hat wie
das zugesendet und dann würde ich sagen
komm mir zu fact nummer drei nummer drei
ist etwas was sie gerade eingeblendet
seht und zwar an halloween tragen einige
mops einen kürbis als helm der cdu schon
da habe ich einfach einen screenshot
weil ich an halloween ehrlich gesagt
noch nie minecraft gespielt habe da war
ich immer irgendwie auf einer party oder
irgendwo draußen oder so also das kann
ich selbst nicht mit irgendwelchen
ingame-szenen hier zeigen allerdings ist
es so dass an halloween einige mops
einfach einen helm tragen weiß ich nur
sagen dass du als easter egg gedacht hat
oder so als special feature gta iv gta 4
war es ja auch so dass rockstar games an
weihnachten überall so schnell gemacht
hat war auch ganz geil und ich muss echt
sagen das ist echt eine ganz tolle
aktion und ich habe es in der letzten
folge sagt man macht nicht viel für die
community finde ich echt spitze und das
ist jetzt auf jeden fall was was ich auf
jeden fall auch mal
erleben muss das jetzt so ein ereignis
was ihr wohl ich auf jeden fall dabei
sein muss aber naja das ist auf jeden
fall an halloween der fall und das
effekt nummer drei nächste serie wurde
mit zugesendet von laien oder leon oder
ich weiß es nicht jedenfalls schreibt
der mann konnte ich habe letztens einen
kleinen oder der unnötigen
herausgefunden und zwar wenn eine spinne
neben drei blöcke dem boden was also
dass drei blöcke luft zwischen den
blöcken und den spinnweben sind platz
fühlst du dich dann der unterstützung
springs bleibst du trotzdem darin hängen
ergo steve springt aus dem stand über
ein meter wo wir haben ja schon erfahren
da oben ist übrigens das skelett dafür
dass next meinte letztens schon mal
gelernt diese entfernung von hier von
hier bis nach hier ist ein meter also
ein blog ist quasi ein mal ein meter
das heißt wir sind drei blöcke also hier
seht ihr es hier zack zack zack dann
kommt das spinnennetz ist ein quasi drei
meter das heißt wenn ich jetzt hoch
springen und auch einspringen bin ich
jetzt quasi drei meter hoch und wenn ihr
seht wie hochspringer sagt das ist auf
jeden fall mehr als ein meter also circa
1 meter 20 würde ich sagen weil 150 in
die mitte vom spinnennetz ja 1 10 21
oder so spring steve auf jeden fall hoch
außen stand das ist extrem gut und
zweimal bei wikipedia nachgeschaut steht
laut wikipedia liegt der durchschnitt
bei olympia springen aus dem stand bei 1
bis 15 metern das heisst yves wäre mit
seinem sprung hier olympia verdächtig
man sich mal vorstellen also schon krass
ist er aus dem stand zu einem einen
meter oder noch ein bisschen höher
springen kann und ich meine auch mal so
rein theoretisch wenn man sich das
vorstellt da hinten
diese blöcke denkt man sich wirklich
locker hoch das ist ja eigentlich immer
einen meter hoch und fünfter also ein
meter hoch so ganz locker aus dem stand
also ein mieter natürlich ich weiß ich
kann man einen meter aus dem stand hoch
und faber mann hüpfte einfach so hoch
das ist riesig krass wenn man sich das
vorstellt will ich aber naja das ist auf
jeden fall effekt nur motto 5 der mit
zugesandt wurde von laien ecke oder leon
ich weiß es nicht auf jeden fall danke
an die nächste sache wurde mir
zugesendet von 0
ohne gaming buddies unterstrich youtube
und zwar auch über dieses coole format
lv formular was ja auch eine
beschreibung findet zombies brennen am
tag aber baby zombies brennt nicht am
tag hat dahin angekreuzt nicht kopieren
als ich habe extra dazu geschrieben
ob ihr den effekt schon mal irgendwo
gesehen hat weil dann nehme ich
natürlich nicht dran oder ob ihr den
einfach noch nirgendwo gesehen hat man
selbst herausgefunden hat und dann habe
ich quasi von euch mal so die sicherheit
okay blabla und sonst halt und dann
nehme ich einfach effekt von euch nicht
mehr dran und bot ihr euch für das
formular muss man sich selbst einfach
überlegen ob man dann wieder ihr wisst
was man jedenfalls setzt sich jetzt die
difficult ich erstmal auf 1 born hier
ganz viele zombies bis endlich mal vom
baby zombie kommt und da haben wir auch
schon haben wir hier auch schon ein baby
zombie digital auf mein kumpel
eigentlich kann ich ihnen nur retten
indem ich ihn einfach töte weil wieder
nicht mehr auf den fokussiert sind
und da der einzige baby zombie der
export ist in fachkreisen schwer einzige
baby zum idee geboren wurde hat jetzt
dahin im wasser herum das ist natürlich
nicht so gut wenn die alle im wasser
sind zwar dass noch ein baby zombie uns
hat er geschrieben dass alle bei tag
brennen außerdem babys tommy das spex
times and day und ihr seht schon alle
fach an zu brennen außer natürlich die
darin im wasser planschen und der baby
zombie hier der ist nicht verpackt oder
sondern er kann natürlich rumlaufen da
seht ihr es der fängt nicht an zu
brennen
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt eventuell
die in höhe noch auftreten die normale
zombies treten ja auch in höhlen auf
dann kann ich mir wirklich nicht
erklären aber das ist auf jeden fall
effekt der mit zugesendet wurde von
gaming buddies youtube und er zählt auf
jeden fall und das war jetzt auch schon
der sechste fällt meine ich schon aber
das jetzt 50 weist hat gar nicht habe
ich mich verzählt tatsache
ich habe mich nicht verzählt und zwar
habe ich mal nur darauf geachtet ich hab
mir nehmen eine diashow offen mit den
sechs wo ich bin schon ab dann gilt also
durch und da habe ich immer so obens
effekt 45 und so allerdings habe ich den
unterschiedlicher reihenfolge gebracht
deswegen stand 106 aber jetzt kommt
eigentlich auch vier also keine ahnung
jedenfalls ist der effekt hier etwas was
ihr wieder eingeblendet sie findet ganz
cool mit sachen ein blender enkelin zwar
sollte der kripo ganz zu anfang des
explorers heißen bzw
das ist ein kleiner
beckum diese spot repair herum und zwar
gibt es ja echt dieses bild bot lassen
das wird auch sehr oft auf t shirts
gedruckt als als design einfach und zwar
ist dazu genau dieser aufbau quasi vor
dem krieg erklärt so genau mit den mit
dem skeletten und diese geräusche die er
was uns erwartet so zum beispiel mit
diesen diamanten und so nah am rand so
dann denkt er sich direkt dann kommst du
es und umso in der reihenfolge coltrane
creeping pages also mit denen mit denen
mit den füßen den gelenken und alles
mögliche oder auch night vision for
optimal creeping and identified
everything anklamer tiguan da geht man
von energy star rating ist für den
diamanten das heißt er extra macht sich
damit er sie wenn jemand mit diamanten
rumläuft und wird es eine ganz witzige
zeichnung auf jeden fall auch dieses
early warning systems also dieses
frühwarnsystem dieses sowieso eine bombe
die so vom countdown runter erzählt
finde ich richtig witzig kann man
irgendwie glaub ich auf der mojang seite
oder zu bestellen ich weiß gar nicht
oder ob man das überhaupt noch bestellen
kann dass es auf jeden fall dass der
krieg damals creepers explosiv und das
habe ich mir einfach gedacht nämlich so
als sechste noch mit rein so etwas
kleines ein kleines bildchen und so aber
sonst würde ich auch schon wieder sagen
meine lieben freunde war es das für die
minecraft rechtsfolge wenn es euch
gefallen da will ich mich definitiv für
eine bewertung freuen
drückt den dollar nach oben oder kreis
hinab und klebten aus video drauf und
sonst wenn ihr denkt die felswand voll
scheiße ich habe selber viel bessere
wegschaut und eine beschreibung des
bit.ly schrägstrich weg zum ziel
das ist das was einfach ausfüllen
müssten fünf sekunden und dann habt ihr
eure effekt auch eingesehen nächsten